So, I see we have a problem here.
We need to solve it.
What's going on?
I'm trying to explain to your man here...
...that his procedures won't work with my production schedule.
And I'm not gonna throw my department into chaos...
...just so that he can check off all his little boxes.
And I'm trying to get this man to understand that we have procedures for a reason.
And now that he's part of our company, he doesn't get to be a free agent anymore.
And I'm trying to get him to understand that the whole point of your acquiring us...
...was to benefit from our experience and expertise.
Okay. So, let me get this straight.
Cliff, you're concerned that following the procedures is throwing off...
...and slowing down your production schedule.
And when Cliff doesn't follow the procedures...
...it creates problems for your reporting and compromises accuracy?
Does that sum it up?
Pretty much.
That's the thumbnail, yeah.
Good. Now we know the problem, we can figure out how to solve it.